muzeu vësh ndërtuar në kështjela në krujes në tëmajtë të hurjesë së saj.
Aju hapë për vizitore të më njënë nëtortë të vitit njëmijënë në 1812.
Arkitektëtë të muzeut janë prambera Hoxha dhe Pirovaso.
Ky muzeu ndërtuar në kruj pas ja jo ishtë kruje cendra e rezistensës shqiptare të shëjkullit pësëmbëdhjet kundër Osmanve
du gëubër kështu nje jemër i njëor për të gjithë Evropën.
Turqite rëthuanë tri herë kështjela në krujesë në vitin 1450, 1466 dhe 1467,
du ke mundurtë apushtojnë atë vetëm në vitin 1478.
Në dërtesa e muzeut ka karakteri në një memoriali.
Në zhjithje në jashtë me arkitektonike, shuën du vëlimë kuresore, pjesa e shtrirë horizontalë me salatë me dha kuresore
e trajtuar vizualishtë sikula të shqiptarve të veri të venditë.
Hapsira të brendshme janë zjedhër në menyrë që mjedise të ndërthuren, du ke kryurë një hapsirë të vetme të penderprer,
ashtu si qëshë edhe thelbi historisë se trajtuar në këtë muze.
Në ndërtim janë përdorur element arkitektonikh historikë, trar të rënë në harqe guri, vejprë arti,
gdëndje në dru, hekuri rahur, harta grafike, piktura në gjamë me të tirë elemenënë,
të cile pë të tërë se bashku marinë blëre në një materialinë dimës historië.
Në tërësi, historia, arkitektura dhe arti në këtë muze për bëngë një të tërë.
Muzeu hapet me një grup skulpturoër që e parajë që djergjë kastriotinë në mestë populitë.
Këtu, figura të lufttarve nuk janë të emërtura,
për vejshetë të ture tregojnë çart pjesmarje në të gjitha krahinave në lufë për mbrojtjen e venditë.
Për ruas tregojnë pjesmarje në ture që të ashtunë në luftime.
Kjo gravur urealizuar nga skulptore të janaj pacho dhe gens hajdari.